one of the things I love about what you
do is you've always taken big sort of I
don't want to call it risks but you've
invested heavy on surrounding yourself
with Heavy Hitters interviewing Heavy
Hitters and also you know we all know in
social media in the podcast world it's a
lot of the same people making the rounds
but one of the things you've done really
well is Chase that Championship mindset
across industry across Niche from
interviewing you know former mafia
members to Kobe Bryant presidents of
countries what have you learned I know
it's kind of a you know sort of a
sidebar but what have you learned along
your journey of success that has been
probably the most interesting or the
most um I guess insightful thing that
you didn't see on the way up now that
you've connected you know you
interviewed Kobe not too long before he
passed rest in peace code but you know
what are some of the things you picked
up about the championship mindset that
kind of you you realize later on down
the road so I'm going to say something
uh yeah I know oh this guy's being this
and that but I'm gonna tell you exactly
how I view this so for me uh we had a
meeting one day and I told Mario I said
Mario
these guys are asking us to go speak at
that event I don't want to speak at that
event because if I speak at that event
I'm in that box if I go speak in that
event everyone's going to see me as in
that Community or that Community or this
community I don't relate to that
Community they're great they're doing
fantastic should I do four speaking gigs
per year not because we get four we get
hundreds per year I only do four and
it's very intentional which ones I go to
and why I do those events okay no
problem so he says why not this so let
me tell you who I relate to and I wrote
all the names on this board never forget
this meeting I said here's this guy
here's that guy here's her here's that
Community here's this here's that here's
this
um
these are the three I want to get close
to because these are the three I relate
to and I wrote the names down okay
everything became very focused about
going that route makes sense can I ask
what those three names are no I'm not I
I won't give you the names but there
were these three names said that I that
I uh went to you can ask it but I'm I
don't want to uh uh you know and I said
this is this is the Target on where I'm
going after and what I'm not going after
and
we came back and he says Pat you sure
you want to do this yes how come you
don't want to do that I said that's not
the long-term vision of what I want to
do
I'm solving for this this is where I
want to go let me tell you it's a little
uh of a risk that you're taking because
what happened during that four or five
year period
you have to assume that individually
without needing that Community you can
make it to that level that Garner is the
right to say these are the three I
relate to right so it's not a
it's a very very big risk the easier
move is to to do what to just go in hey
can I borrow your do you know anything
no if that guy calls in I'm going
okay if that guy calls and I want to be
part of his community
I want to be in his Circle I want to
have a relationship with him but I don't
want to prostitute my brand right okay
just like in high school or in the
military you know everybody had a click
and if you're part of that click you are
that click yeah so if somebody from the
outside sees you know he's just a
funnels guy he's just a this guy oh he's
just that guy or he's just a motivation
I don't want to be that yeah so I'm like
no I'm not going to be doing this so
people are like how come you never
interviewed that one guy
how come you've never interviewed that
one guy how come you've never entered
this one uh it's not what I'm solving
for I don't want to solve for that so we
were a little bit more intentional in
that area it was a risk you know because
some people say well you got to be
kidding me you would write an interview
mobsters and interview them uh this has
nothing to do with character the people
that I didn't go in with that community
that has nothing to say about their
character they're very good people
better people than maybe some of the
other you know uh people I interviewed
but I was interested in that story I
wanted to go slightly a different angle
uh risk came with it a lot of risk came
with it but eventually you know similar
thing to us when you build your company
you don't go ask money up front we can
uh if you start your company and you ask
money up front you're giving up Equity
you're control too early
versus if you wait to go get Equity
later on
you know you're you're asking for cash
later on you're only giving up a little
bit of equity somebody cannot tell you
how to run out of work how to do this
how to do that I don't want to call an
approval and say hey we're about to pay
a million dollars for this okay let us
get four people to approve this it's
going to take a month and a half I don't
want to call you and get an approval I
just want to say here's the money we're
spending right what if I give up 51 of
equity to somebody else I can't do that
well I own 83 the company so I'm not
going to give it up to lose the control
with that that same thing happens when
you all of a sudden go into too many of
these circles then
um you you're you're losing too much
control again uh some may say yeah you
know he's just talking this this is my
philosophy and it's work
[Music]